elle est à l'ordre mais le spectacle a à
a
et oui il ya autre chose c'est une
interview vous faites avec ma voix et
qui s'appelle l'interview mais ce rallye
lieu idéal pour aînés train propos ainsi
si le matelas pneumatique parce que j'en
ai acheté 1 et qu'ils aillent et puis je
suis allé le maître bon la fenêtre de ma
soeur est ce que c'est là-bas que
j'habite donc le lamih avec des pinces à
linge puis il ya deux ans il ya eu la
fameuse tempête ya deux ans donc le
matelas et par qui va gagner jusqu'à
jusqu'au voisin boom voisins depuis la
tempête puis s'il habite à un kilomètre
2 quand même et il est revenu puis là il
ya eu des trous partout à cause du
rougier ont l'art rustines et est depuis
bon bah c'est là dessus que j'aimerais
bien avoir une étreinte
enfin si ça vient quand on est toujours
beaucoup les lettres échangées ou
investir que oui c'est face à avancer
bon je faisais pas mal de collection
dont je vais beaucoup de collections de
73 cents les 14 sont nuls 15 77 après
deux ans j'ai arrêté parce que 3 est
descendu en d2 après après 3 devenue la
grande équipe de foot que tout le monde
connaît donc moi j'ai grandi aussi donc
je fais plus de collection donc même en
provence j'ai plus grand chose à
échanger
j'étais petit en bas à une poule quand
j'étais petit vous étiez plus intéressés
par le foot et foot que par l'école et
vous connais cirer les joueurs de
football
telle est bien sûr mais aussi par les
magazines par des magazines comme france
foot en france ah oui et alors passé une
sorte de questions fusent gisèle et qui
fond sous baulois jeu
si je dis oui ça peut marcher oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait la dernière chose
que vous faites avant de vous brancher
le soir la dirigeante que je me couche
le soir je m'assois que moi je me couche
feriez quoi pas pareil quoi pas pareil
l'entrée de schémas silencieux quand
j'arrive avec le matelas pneumatique il
remporte donc et puis je refais le
papier peint en orange qui est assez
moche
en tout cas je crois que c'est ce que je
ferais pas pareil je crois à 22 heures
salle 2
voilà vous dites dans le spectacle que
votre rêve c'est d'être invité dans tout
le monde en parle et comme ça n'arrivait
pas muni vous avez réalisé merci tiens
je vais tomber
non
m
il avait vraiment j'y croyais étaient
des faux annoncé par poser savez quoi
c'est jamais mois avec van persie